this is my version of Dei you get your
company you get a couple positions just
for women you appoint them then when
anything goes wrong you blame them they
do you're like this is all the women's
fault there's nothing look it's girl
power and all but with with great girl
power comes great girl responsibility
there was a there there was a black
woman who posted on Instagram that she
gets her face put on all the corporate
brochures she never gets brought into
meetings and she's like this is how you
know you're a diversity hire yeah but I
mean guys there are gender R some women
are not going to be plumbers like you
know what I mean I I don't know why we
don't just yeah cuz the patri stops them
we should encourage
thisan no they they stop themselves like
that's that's what country a country
full of men who allow women to do gross
jobs is a country that doesn't have
enough you enough men you'd have to
conscript them that's the reality women
are all all good when they're like but I
deserve to be CEO of the company but as
soon as you're like please go to the oil
rig they're like I cannot no thank you
that would be mean to to me I'm not
equipped for that they don't want any of
the responsibilities that men take on
because like any sort of negative or
less glamorous position women don't want
that they only want to have the uh
Heralds and acolytes that they they
perceive that men are getting and they
aren't willing to pay the consequences
for that it's completely ridiculous
system that they have invented and the
end result is social collapse because
but what about the Disney director they
said they want to make people
uncomfortable make unable imagine if
right now so here's what we have we have
women who want equality in equity in the
workplace they call it they want 50/50
parody then you have men who keep saying
no no no women shouldn't go work in the
sewers and sludge around in human waste
we'll do that
job the system would collapse overnight
if men actually just all at once
completely agreed and said you know what
half the people on our team in the sewer
you know cleaning out all the sewage and
the blockages should be female then they
say well there aren't any then we won't
work I will not go down there until my
team is half male half female you have
to create like a weird Title Nine but
it's to get women to do like gross jobs
in society women will not do it so if
men one day decided I won't then Society
collapses because women will not there
will never be a circumstance where you
will mandate half the population of
women to go work on oil rigs it's just
not going to happen I mean and this is
true in domestic labor too right like we
know there's a ton of stuff that that
girls just don't want to do they're
happy to do other things and I think
that's what bothers me the most about
you know the femin feminist narr
narrative which is that it's essentially
saying men are the en enemy and they're
keeping you from doing things that would
make you happy but also we are not
willing to compromise we want all the
benefits of being female also we want
all the benefits of being male we want
none of the responsibility of either sex
yeah well that's right and I mean look
the reality is there's there are a lot
of things that men aren't going to do
either right there there's a lot of
domestic L lot of stuff around the house
I mean we're really not going to do that
but there's a lot of stuff around the
house that for the most part aren't
going to want to do there's a lot of
Homemaker stuff there's a lot of stay
like stay at home Dad well when we start
imp planting those WS right no no when
we make uh artificial baby bags what men
are inventing a way to have babies
without women oh my gosh they have to
make one of those that yells at you and
then that's
a that's a joke women are wonderful and
I'm saying it's men doing it because the
overwhelming majority of the people
working in these fields and doing the
development and the research are males
men are are are going to create a way to
have babies without women men are going
to go their own way
so all the sci wait if that happened do
you think no but do you think gay men
lesbian women would take of the world if
they could just artificially who win
yeah because that's what it's going to
be ar I'm just saying this is my point
I'm saying if they artificially make a
womb then they basically want to get rid
of heterosexual sex or they want to you
know they want to make something totally
different if we create artificial wombs
women lose all political power they will
lose I don't think so all yeah
absolutely I think women could I think I
don't think people value women as
mothers anymore anyway like I think it's
all about like sexual objectification
and their sexual power and and and so
what's going to happen is with neuralink
and baby bags women lose all political
power I think that's true because I
think you already said that with the
modern sery right I mean this is what
Pope Francis was talking about today
that he was saying it is ultimately a
form of trafficking and it's wrong for
children it's despicable this is like
his word for work quote and I think that
women I mean I think it's two things I
think basically their voluntary
participation in the porn industry them
deciding they want to be an only fans
and also voluntary participation in
commercial surrogacy makes it so
anything they have to offer the world
can be commodified and sold for a dollar
and probably you can make artificial
technology that does it better like a
baby bag like AI porn and so I think
this is a mistake that women are making
and I think on top of that we're
severing the value of parents right men
and women both play a really important
role in their children's lives from the
beginning of time and this is true while
while women are gestating M male uh men
still play an important role and it's
true after birth they play yes but the
denuclearization is what they've been
talking about forever yeah and I think
that's what's sad it's like saying
everything that we that makes us unique
as human beings that gives us humanity
is ultimately something you can buy
trade and sell and probably we could
make some soulless metal contraption
that could do it better well you know
what and that's not true in my opinion
you're right because when it comes to
human labor and when it comes to
production the only thing we think about
anymore is the end product that actually
ends up being produced by the process
and not what the person is transformed
into through the work and so we see this
with jobs being broken up into
components so small that a person can't
really find that much meaning in their
work because they don't actually have
any kind of vision of the larger picture
in the way that they're contributing to
it and it's a very very sad thing I was
having a conversation with someone a few
months ago and they said something very
eye-opening to me um he was just talking
about how how people used to live and
how we would farm and we were much more
in tune with the seasons and the the
days and and sort of our own circadian
rhythm was not as thrown off by the
technology we used and I remember saying
like I get it and people can romanticize
that but that was tremendously difficult
that was a tremendously difficult life
to live and those jobs were far harder
than than sitting in an office and
working in an office and he said yeah
but is sitting in an office better for
you and it kind of clicked for me I'm
not I'm not saying that go back to an
agrarian society by any means but my
point is just that it's interesting food
for thought the jobs that we have even
though they're more productive they're
actually not good for us and people
might argue oh well these new ways of
having technology usurp roles that were
traditionally meant for human beings or
things like artificial wombs literally
taking that role which was just uniquely
for women and turning it into a
technological product that's really bad
for human beings it's really bad for
human beings no I think you're exactly
right I mean I would say 95% of
corporate jobs you really get no stake
in the game so even though you can be
motivated with bonuses if you really
don't care about what you're doing and
and you don't have anybody that's up in
that company you know I guess you know
supporting you or gassing you up or
encouraging you to do better why would
you thrive in a system like that if you
don't really have any stake in the game
exactly because at some point money just
isn't enough to get you to do a certain
kind of job it really is not enough you
have to actually believe in what you're
making did you ever hear about that uh I
don't know if the story is true or not
but the professor Who challenged the
students on socialism it's like a viral
Tik Tock or Instagram video where he
basically said they were arguing the
merits of socialism versus you know
capitalism so then the professor said
here's what we're going to do we're
going to average out the grades of every
single person in the class so that
everyone will get an average grade
instead of the grade for your test and
then the first test they take every
everyone ends up getting like a like a a
C+ and a b or a B minus and then the
people who studied really really hard
and and scored a 100 order on the test
were angry cuz they were like I I busted
my my ass studying and I ended up
getting a bad grade because of this the
people who did nothing were super
excited because they were like I got a
great grade and didn't have to do
anything why do anything else so the
people who studied hard said I'll adjust
I don't got to work as hard because I
don't get any any reward for working as
hard so I'll invest my time somewhere
else the next test they took everyone
got a C minus now people are starting to
get angry like why is our score who's
not holding their weight who's not doing
the work and then finally in the third
time everybody failed because anybody
worth doing work was like what's the
point when other people are celebrating
not doing work that's right and by the
way that's the best case scen iio for
Socialism or communism what what usually
ends up happening with Communist
governments is after the first test they
round up all the people who did score
100% and say you got that by cheating
and then they execute them well no I'm
I'm antisocial ISM 100% but is
capitalism the best system I mean I I
guess it is but it needs modifications
say I well I don't know I mean I guess
some mix I mean I feel like there I'm
actually you know I don't want the
government involved at all but I do feel
like I don't know I don't know what a
system I mean yeah capitalist economy in
my view a capitalist economy with with
some uh regulation I'm saying like
imagine but that's not a mixed economy a
mixed economy like we have is we half
your money goes to taxes and half your
money goes in your pocket right yeah we
need a flat tax I mean that's one thing
I mean our just and I'm sure you're in a
totally different tax bracket Tim you
must be sick you I mean I'm sick now cuz
I'm in a higher bracket than I've been
in the past years but it's not just
bracket I think something like 65 or 70%
of all my income is taxes or some I mean
I PID over 40% I paid over 40% I think
it was like 40 so here here's here's the
trick they don't tell you about um
higher taxes means spending more money
yeah I know yeah if if you're somebody
let's say you make a million bucks a
year and you look at your taxes and like
Joe Biden's raising your taxes if I
let's say I have $100,000 in profit I
don't spend it y I write a check to the
government for 40 Grand how about I just
spend the 100 Grand and retain the asset
value that's right but it's got to be
specific things like I'll just say screw
it instead of having the money sitting
around I'll just hire a guy at 100,000
to paint because at least the paintings
are assets held by the company that
retain value and then I don't lose the
money to the government well have you
seen the Tik Tok that goes viral where
it's it's like Bill 179 where if you buy
a G wagon because it weighs over 6,000
pounds you can write it off for a
company and that's why so many people
buy the G wagon it's gotten you know
hundreds of millions of hits you need to
look it up because and there's a few
cars that um hit that tax certain but
they they control they they can control
the speed and expansion of the economy
that's the point of the Federal Reserve
it's the point of their tax policy
modern monetary theory is not you're
taxed so that the government gets money
know the the the government just creates
money on upon the Agents of debt taking
money from you is just to control the
speed at which people are hiring and
firing people well and that's the thing
right so as somebody who does uh run
their own business when you get your
paycheck they don't deduct anything from
it right you're collecting money from
from clients or AdSense or sponsors and
then you have to cut that check yourself
eventually quarterly or once a year feel
you really feel it and the thing is you
feel it and you go if I really believed
in what the government was doing this
wouldn't hurt so bad like if I really
even though this is way too much money
and I don't think anyone should be taxed
at this level and I I I really think
there's something wrong with govern if I
believed they thought they were doing
good things with it it wouldn't Hur
nearly as bad it really would I got to
be honest um based on how much money
I've already been taxed I as a single
individual I'm probably responsible for
like I don't know at least one wedding
that's been blown up yeah more than
yeah but isn't this what they say about
uh Scandinavian countries that have high
social security Nets is that they
actually say like like people in Denmark
are like no no we're we're cool to pay
these taxes because ultimately we like
the benefits that we reap from them I
mean it's one of the reasons that they
are so disturbed by mass immigration
which is that they realize there are
people coming in who don't pay into the
system I mean there are people that have
extremely high tax rates they have a
large you know social safety net from
the government and it's okay it's just
not true in America because our system
doesn't doesn't have either one of the
benefits right it's fair it's not equal
we we don't have the the benefits that
people might want and we don't have the
low but we have the high taxes so what
are we ultimately doing here I think I
think the challenge one of the big
challenges is uh stupid people versus
smart people and evil people as well so
like when I look at the Democrats what
do I tend to see there are very few but
very smart evil people and a whole lot
of really really dumb people when I look
at the quote unquote right I don't mean
just the Democrats because the right is
a collection of Libertarians conserva I
see a lot of people who are moderately
intelligent and a handful of people who
are very very stupid because every
because stupid people exist everywhere
but if you have a handful of people who
uh if you have commentators on the right
who are like I'll try to be honest and I
believe in Liberty which means you got
to make your own choices the stupid
people end up with a moderately better
understanding of the world and their
freedoms whereas the Democrats believe
inan insane things that make no sense
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net